India is set to overtake China as the
country with the largest population this
is expected to happen in the next three
months the United Nations report says
that by April
um India will have more people than
China and that by 2050 there will be
almost 1.7 billion people living in
India compared to China's expected 1.31
billion in fact China's population is
expected to decline and this is because
of strict family pre planning rules that
have contributed to a low birth rate now
economically economically China is still
considered much more of a Powerhouse
than India but of course over time that
may change as well right now the big
conversation in terms of superpowers is
U.S China Russia but that could very
quickly change what Dynamics do you
expect would be different if and when
India overtakes China not just in terms
of population but economically